okay we're gonna have an R session now
in our studio we've learned about some
some techniques for for fitting linear
regression models and now we're going to
see how we do it in r
so you'll see I've got a session open in
our studio with some uh commands that
I've already typed in and I'm just going
to go through these with you and and
we'll see some of the features in our
for fitting regression models
okay so here we are
we've got a script window over here and
we'll send commands down to the console
so first we'll do library Mass which has
some data sets that we're going to
access and then we'll do go Library islr
which is our own library with data sets
used in the book okay and so first of
all we'll do simple linear regression
so one of the data sets is the Boston
data and it's got a bunch of variables
and if you say names of Boston you see
all the names of the variables
well they kind of abbreviated names and
so if you want more detail you can ask
for help on Boston so we do that by
putting a question mark before Boston
Boston's a data frame
and in the right panel now we see
the help file for house for the Boston
so we see its housing values in suburbs
of Boston
it's got 506 rows and 14 columns
and and now it tells you details about
each of the variables
so so Chrome for example is per capita
crime rate by town
ZN is proportion of residential land
zone for Lots over 25 000 square feet
and so on if you go down the list
and these are all features about these
regions
in Boston and they sort of summary
features that describe the
socio-economic conditions in those
regions
elstat lower status of the population
percentage so it's a percentage of the
population that in that region that's of
lower status
and Med V is median value of
owner-occupied homes in in a hundred
thousand dollars so you can do help on
on data frames
okay so the first thing we do is we put
a linear model
um
oh I beg your pardon the first thing we
do is plot
some variables so we'll plot
um Med V and lstat the two variables we
just mentioned and Comet Boston which
tells the plot function to find those
variables in in the data frame Boston
and by using a Twitter between Med V and
lstat you're actually telling that that
really the response is made V that's the
the median
um housing value it's going to put that
on the vertical axis and so there's the
plot on the right and sure enough as
as the um the lower status in in the
region percentage increases the median
housing value decreases
we'll fit a linear model now to those
data and you'll see the formula is the
same as we used in the plot and we call
that fit one
and there it's fit and then we'll print
it out
and it gives us an intercept and a
coefficient and sure enough the
coefficients negative as you can see
there's a negative relationship
so printing out a linear model fit gives
you a very brief summary and for a more
detailed summary you can say summary of
it
and when we do that we get a lot more
so we get residuals some of it's got cut
off here if you just look up you see you
get the call that created the fit
you get
and then you get the coefficients
they're standard errors
T values and P values and both of these
are very significant
we're typically not interested too much
in The Intercept it's the coefficient of
lstat that we're interested here and
it's negative and very significantly so
and then there's some other submarine
material underneath which we'll maybe
touch on a bit later
Okay so one the nice thing so notice in
the formula here we we
had the response on the left hand side
twiddle means to be it means is modeled
as and then lstat is the single
predictor in this case and then we give
the name of the data frame where these
variables can be found
so that's a standard format for for 15
linear models and the other options too
but for the moment we won't need them
now we can add that linear model fit to
the plot and there's a function called a
b line in R which
is able to pick up a linear model and
just do that and you'll see in the right
hand plot and it was
um
augmented with the the line that
corresponds to the fit
okay
um now
we've done various things with the fit
we've we've plotted it with this a b
line we've looked at it with summary and
with print by just printing its name you
can see what other components on it
actually has got quite a few components
these are largely to do with the details
of fit in the model and we won't trouble
ourselves too much with them but
basically you can see the coefficients
on the on the fit
and that was picked up by the summary
and then a whole lot of other things
that I used
um rather internally so we won't really
concern ourselves with them
confident finds your confidence interval
for the fit and
and in this case it gives a confidence
interval for the coefficients and by
default it gives the low 25 percent and
upper 97.5 percent
balance so this is a 95 confidence
interval for each of those coefficients
um the predict function is another one
of these these methods that that we can
use to to query a a linear model fit in
this game case we're going to predict
with three new values for lstat or three
particular values 5 10 and 15 and we're
gonna not only ask for predictions we're
going to ask for a confidence interval
so those are additional arguments to
predict
and when we do that we get the fit at
those three values and then the lower
confidence interval and the upper
confidence band
and so you can give as many values as
you like and get this lower and and
upper values
so that's simple linear regression
let's move on to multiple linear
regression and now we fit a linear model
for 2 which is going to be a linear
model with lstat and age and that we
separate those with a plus in the right
hand side of the formula
and and we can fit that and do a summary
well it's just much like we had before
except now we've got two coefficients
two standard plus the intercepts so
three all together with the standard
errors T value and P values
and age is also significant
quite strongly so but not as significant
as as elstadt
at the one of the things down below is
the r squared which we talked about as
well
um for the model remember r squared it's
the higher the better
it's a percentage of variants explained
and uh
it also gives you a summary
other summary of the model the if
statistic is the F statistic that we'd
obtain if we dropped out both of the
predictors in this model
for three we're gonna for the linear
model with response made V and it goes
twiddle Dot and what that signifies is
that we're supposed to use all the other
variables in the Boston data frame
except made V which is the response and
all the others will be predictors
and sure enough when we do a summary of
that model you see there's a lot of
coefficients and
they each get the estimate the standard
error the T value and the p-value
most of them are significant some are
not age now is no longer significant
so age when it was in the model just
with elstat was significant but now
it's in the model with all these other
predictors and it's no longer
significant in other what that means is
there's basically a lot of other
predictors that are very correlated with
age
and in the presence of them age is no
longer required
let's do a plot you can plot linear
models I made a two by two layout
because I know that there's four plots
get get produced when you do a plot
these are a little smaller but um we can
see what's going on these give you
various views of the linear model the
first one is the residuals against the
fitted values
the fitted the vector of fitted values
is just a single Vector so we can plot
the residuals against that
and the reason we do that is we we're
looking for non-linearities and we kind
of know there's a non-linearity in this
one we saw that in the very first plot
and by the curve in the residuals here
we can see that the model's not quite
capturing everything that's going on
there seems to be some non-linearity
and this these other plots which are
somewhat beyond the scope of what we're
doing here today
um
that that give you aspects of the um of
the linear model fit
um this one here is this lower left one
is the square root of the absolute
standardized residuals
um when
plots this to see perhaps if the if the
variance is changing with the with the
mean or the fit in this case it looks
like there may be some relationship
there but that could be a result of the
non-linearity that we seem to have
missed in the model
update is a nice command you fit a model
for three and you can update it
um and in this case we're going to
update with the formula we give is
twiddle dot minus age
twiddle means we nothing on the left
means we're going to use the same
response
dot means whatever the model was in fit
three that's replaced in Dot and minus
age means we want to remove age and
minus in this we want to remove Indus as
well so this will fit the model with
those two variables removed all the
others in
and sure enough if we do the fit we see
that those two variables are out and now
everything that's left in the model
appears to be significant
okay moving on
non-linearities
we'll and interactions the first thing
we'll do is make a fit where we put an
interaction between lstat and age
um and that we do with a star
sort of like multiply but in in this
formula language it means an interaction
and we've just got those two variables
in the model and so when we do a summary
of the fit we see that we get
the main effect for lstata main effect
for age and then the interaction which
here is represented as a colon so that
star in the formula means that we're
going to have main effects for each and
the interaction and the pure interaction
is is indicated by a colon
and while the main effect for age is is
not significant here the interaction is
somewhat significant
next thing we do is we fit
lstat and we saw that there was a
non-linear looking scatter plot between
Med V and lstat and so here we
explicitly put in a quadratic term
and there's two things going on here the
one is
we've the quadratic we indicate by lstat
power two
but Power has a meaning in this formula
language and so if you wanted to be mean
actually just raise L stat to the power
2 we protect it with this identity
function so the formula language doesn't
dig inside this identity function so it
literally puts in the square of elstead
and the other thing that's going on here
is we've put two commands in one line
which you can do in R but you have to
separate them with a semicolon so you
can have as many commands in one line as
you like but separate them with
semicolons
and
and so both of those commands got
executed now
and sure enough as no surprise both
coefficients are strongly significant
the linear and the quadratic
okay so now we're gonna plot this
what I do now is attach Boston we've
seen this before it means that the the
names the named variables in Boston are
available on on in our data space just
makes it easier for for making nice
looking plots
um we go back to a single pane plot
layout so par MF row equals C11 it means
a one by one layout
and now we'll plot
our two variables there they are we've
seen that plot before and now we'll
include
the quadratic fit
now
we won't we can't use a b line anymore
because that only works when you've got
a straight line fit now we need to
somehow get the fitted values from our
quadratic fit and include them in the
plot
and so we do that with the points
command and the first argument is lstat
itself and this the first argument the
second argument are the fitted values
from fit six that was our quadratic fit
so the fitted values are for each value
of L stat it's the fitted value from the
model so that's exactly what we want and
that will be plotted as a series of
points
and we tell it the color should be red
and the PCH which is the the plotting
character is to be
20. let's see what it does for us first
well it puts a quadratic fit in the in
the in the plot
looks like the plotting character 20 is
a little
um is a little round ball we'll have a
little look in a moment and see a bit
more about that before we do that
there's an easier way of fitting
polynomials and that's to use the poly
function in R and so yeah we're going to
fit Med v as a polynomial of degree 4 in
elstat
and we'll add that to the plot with
color blue
and you can see that the fourth degree
polynomial is is is getting a little bit
too Wiggly it's it's chasing our it's
starting to overfit the data a little
bit especially you can see in the right
tail over here it's maybe you know going
after the these rather
[Music]
um
these rather isolated points here
okay so before we end let's have a look
at what plotting characters are
available so here's a simple way of
seeing them all plot 1 to 21 to 20 and
plotting characters 1 to 20 we can see
the whole lot
and there you see them and so you have
available a whole bunch of plotting
characters actually more than these and
number 20 was sure enough this one over
here
and CX equals 2 means that we want to
enlarge those plotting characters by um
by two you know we want to double the
size
um qualitative predictors
so
car seats is another one of the data
sets
um
okay
[Music]
um
so the command fix is a way of throwing
up an editor in in R so you can actually
look at the data that you're about to
use so it'll throw up a data frame and
allow you to use it
and so here's the car seats data frame
thrown up on the screen maybe a little
bit small for you to use
just wanted to show you that I'll quit
out of that get back to our our studio
session
and
so that's one way of seeing the data
there's the names
um of car seats
and so this is this was a study on on
children's car seats okay
um you can also do a summary of a data
frame and it
for each variable it tells you something
about the values in in the data frame
for that variable
and you can see for quantitative
variables it gives you summaries like
the mean the median and up and lower
quantiles
um but for categorical
um or quantitative variables it actually
gives you a table of the distinct values
okay so shelf lock is a a qualitative
variable in this case
Okay so
so
um
so we'll fit a model for for the car
seats data and
the first call is sales Twitter dot
means everything in the frame but Sales
Plus we're going to add in interactions
between income and advertising and age
and price
and we do that
and sure enough there we get the model
and see if there's again a bunch of
significant variables and there's those
two interactions we put in and income
and advertising
um appears to be strongly significant
but price and age is not
um
show of lock
um
was a categ was a qualitative variable
if you look at contrasts it contrasts
function it shows you how R will code
that variable when it's put in a linear
model
and in this case it's a three level
factor and so it puts in two dummy
variables
and
the values are if show block is bad 0
for both if it's good
the first one is one and the second one
is is zero if it's medium see they're
named actually good and medium
um zero and one and so bad is not
neither good nor medium so that's zero
on both so that you can actually find
out how our codes quantitative variables
the final thing we'll do here is
see some examples of writing R functions
so let's write a little r function to
put a regression model and make a plot
so we start off by saying reg plot is
equal to function of X Y open curly
brace
and then so that open curly brace
indicates that we're going to start
giving the code in our function and the
X and Y says our function is going to
take arguments X and Y
okay and so the first thing we do is
we're going to fit a linear model
between Y and X then we're going to plot
x y and then we're going to a b line the
fit with color equals red and then
and then close curly brace that's the
end of our function
okay so it's a very simple little
function which we've written and so now
let's try it out we'll attach car seats
and we'll do a reg plot of price and
sales so it takes two arguments we've
given it price and sales
and you see the plot on the right
plot silently went off and did that and
produced the plot and put in the line
okay
well let's make our function a little
bit more useful
and you can see I'm defining it with
essentially the same commands
but I've added a dot dot dot in the
arguments and this is a very useful
construct in arm in writing functions
dot dot dot means these are unnamed
arguments but you're allowed to add
extra arguments and they'll get passed
on exactly as they supplied
wherever they're used inside the
function
and here I've passed them on to the plot
function and what that does is it allows
us to add extra arguments to the plot
function via our reg plot
and so now when we make the call we we
call Reg price and sales
and we give it
x-lab and ylab so that tells it how to
annotate the the labels of the the axes
of the plot and we add some color and
and other information see regplot just
called the axes X and Y minimal our
variables were were price and sales
so
now when we make the plot you see the
plot points were colored in blue and
and and the axes were labeled
okay so that's that's a a little
introduction to some of the linear model
um uh software in r the scope is really
large and there's many other things you
can do but you know as always with
software you've got to start at the
beginning and get your hands dirty and
so we've done that a little bit here and
I encourage you to to play with this
yourself and and explore the functions
use the help files and and see how far
you can get